I mean, it was this, you get people scared
and they'll vote, vote a certain way.
And Yeah. So, yeah.
Amazing Times though. Yeah.
As a journalist, do you look at
these times and say, this is great,
this is great for business,
or do you do you more so look
at it as a human being and go,
this is just a fucking mess.
And I wish we weren't so ridiculous.
So when, when I first started
covering the Trump campaign,
I thought this is the most awesome
thing ever because, uh, uh,
that dynamic I was talking
about before about,
about reporters wanting to
be on the ground floor with,
with a future winner. Um,
nobody wanted to be on the Trump campaign
because nobody thought he was going to
win. I was stoked to the assigned, uh,
to cover Trump because I thought this
is the most insane thing ever. And He,
you know, maybe you can for your
style of journalism. Yeah, exactly.
I thought this is,
this is the black comedy that I was
then I was sort of born to cover and,
and born to write. And for
the first, I don't know,
five or six things that I wrote
about it, um, about Trump.
I thought it was the most amazing,
crazy, interesting story of my lifetime.
And then it took this incredibly
dark term where he actually won. And,
um, I think it was a dark
turn for him too. Yeah.
There's no question about
it. No, there's no, I mean,
I knew some of the people in his campaign,
I can't say this definitively,
but I,
I have a very good educated guests that
they had absolutely no expectation of it
ever even been close,
let alone winning and that and that they,
uh,
that they did this as a
publicity stunt in the beginning,
probably with the aim of either creating
a media network or just bolstering
Trump's overall Q rating
or whatever it was.
I think BC might've pushed him towards
the presidency by firing him from the
apprentice. Uh, yeah,
cause he was still the host of that
fucking show while he was running for
president.
They fire him and then Arnold takes over.
People forgot already.
Arnold Schwartzenegger
with for a very short time,
you're fired. You're fired. You're fired.
He was the guy for awhile. Yeah. They
had that flame war remember as, yeah.
It's really weird. Yeah. Fucking strange.
But NBC might have given him the final,
you know,
you might have taken an extra diet
pill that day and went, fuck it.
We're going all in the wall.
Got 10 feet higher
on Swartz.
Bigger says he's done with the apprentice.
Blames poor ratings on Trump
involvement. Oh, that's hilarious.
That's right.
Yeah.
They had that whole back and forth over
who was to blame for the ratings. But uh,
listen, as a host of that
show, Donald Trump was great.
Oh yeah. He's the perfect guys to
host that show. Arnold's too nice.
It's not the right guy. He's
not a billionaire asshole. You,
you need a total jackass and, and
get it done. One of those guys,
you need one of those guys.
You got fired. And the, the,
the same thing that made Trump perfect
for that show made him perfect as the
main protagonist in campaign coverage,
which is actually really just a
really long super boring reality show,
or at least that used to be
until Trump came along. Uh,
Trump completely changed the
dynamic of it. You know, if you're,
if you're thinking of it in terms
of how it looks to a network,
what were the networks thinking before,
if they,
if they were going to have people like
Scott Walker and Lindsey Graham be the
stars of,
of their lead reality show.
Like let's get a real performer in
there. Right? And, and when they did,
when they,
when,
when Trump entered the fray and became
a real candidate and started getting
votes,
suddenly news started making money and
like for like real money for the first
time. And there was a, there's
an amazing data point right now,
which is that the public trusts
the press less than ever, right?
They believe the things that we say
less than ever, all the polls show this,
that there's been a dramatic downturn
and how much people will put stock.
And things that people
like me say, right? Uh,
but they're watching television,
a new television news more
than they ever have by a lot.
So what are those two
data points say together,
put together that people are
consuming news not as news,
but it's entertainment there. There, there
are watching it more. Right. So we're,
we've, you know, CNN made
over $1 billion last year.
They're just eating into the
entertainment budget. That's,
that's all they're doing. And
it's all Trump. Uh, which is,
is fascinating and kind of horrifying,
but, but really interesting too.
Isn't that also what he played
upon when he was running?
Like he would say outrageous shit.
So they would cover him and
that essentially gave him
free press. Oh, absolutely.
Yeah. And He, there was
no doubt in my mind that,
that he was doing that intentionally.
I remember watching him,
and I'm in New Hampshire where he's
giving a speech and you probably remember
this, this woman stood up and said,
ted Cruz is the pussy. All right. Yeah.
And,
uh,
and Trump looks over at her and he says,
oh, that's terrible. That's terrible.
She just said a terrible thing about
Ted Cruz. Right. And I remember,
I remember him looking over at the,
at the rise of where all the cameras are,
and you could see him thinking, he's
thinking it's, it's a story for six hours.
If she says it, it's a story for three
days. That's why I say it. Right. Right.
And he, he thinks, and he goes, he just
said that Ted Cruz, the pussy a right.
And next thing you know, it
like completely dominated
the news. And, and he,
he completely, he understood the dynamic
of how the news works better than,
than even the people in the
news understood it. Well,
certainly better than Ted Cruz. Yeah.
That's for sure. Ted Cruz, that the,
the recent praise of Trump and then they
go back to like what he said during the
campaign.
Oh my God.
It's no one should ever listen to him
ever again about anything. Oh yeah, no,
it was, it was, it, it's
hilarious. Ted Cruz, you know,
first of all,
my favorite part of that whole campaign,
what's the thing that he couldn't shake
about being the Zodiac killer? Like, uh,
and, and reporters would
give him shit about it. Like,
we would talk amongst each other, like,
who's going to ask him about it the next,
you know, and, and, um, and everybody knew
that it was, it was bullshit. You know,
that he was born after the killing
started and everything, all that stuff.
But somebody would always make
it a point to say, so what,
what do you think about the,
you know, the rumors about,
and you could see that it just,
it completely drove him to distraction.
He didn't know how to, how to
make a joke out of it or, yeah.